je
pense moi j'étais incroyable et tout
disparaît dans cette maison c'est à
croire qu'il ya des fantômes
j'aurais posé mon livre il y a cinq
minutes sur cette table eh bien il n'y a
plus
on va tant pis ou tant pis je n'irai pas
je vais finir mon puzzle voilà
oui mais il est il était là montpezat
ont été posées sur cette chaise depuis
un mois depuis le jour où j'ai commencé
il n'a pas pu disparaître comme ça en
kazemi tu as un de tourner en rond et de
marmonner je ne peux pas venir
tranquillement j'ai besoin de calme -
c'est incroyable non seulement son
renard de malheur s'est installée chez
moi mais en plus jeauneau dérange
oui tu me gêne tu mens nuit tu me
dérange es-tu m'agace voilà tu fais des
courants d'air en allant de droite à
gauche tu n'arrêtes pas de grogner
j'ai besoin de me concentrer
ils me font du sila
mais c'est mon livre c'est si l'histoire
extraordinaire de touba à les autres la
non moins alors bravo alors non
seulement tu me prends mes livres mais
en plus tu me prends mes expressions
favorites celle qui m'ont rendu célèbre
krasimir ce livre est dans ma main donc
il est à moi ce n'est pas une raison ce
livre était sur ma table si les dents tu
as mal c'est toi qui lis ami est d'abord
qui sait très bien que j'étais en train
de le lire je regrette ça n'était pas
écrit dessus toute façon à part c'est
malin c'est malin vraiment un si tu
pouvais au moins aller te promener un
instant à nous laisser tranquille mais
je ne vois pas pourquoi j'irais me
promener alors que je suis en train de
le livre un livre avec des histoires
formidables et qu'il passionne voilà
très bien alors c'est moi qui m'en vais
je te laisse
et je ne vous salue pas monsieur
les enfants au basket on lance la balle
comme ça restera comme ça les deux mains
tous contre moi pas mal vous ne savez
plus rapide tu es un bon jour casimir
salut kazemi a bien joué au ballon avec
nous on s'entraîne non merci non
continuer à jouer sans moi les enfants
désignés qu'est-ce qu'il ya tu n'as pas
l'air d'être dans ton assiette eu un
problème ouais j'ai un problème qui a
deux grandes oreilles et cry mauvais
caractère casimir tu veux sans doute
parler de léonard exactement nos côtes
et il fait encore bien chaque fois que
je commence en libre il terminé chaque
fois que je commence un jeu il a défait
aucun numéro sociaux pour très grave tu
vas pas en vouloir à léonard pour si peu
de choses enfin enfin c'est pas parce
que quelqu'un a mauvais caractère on va
tout lui pardonner ou d'accords casimir
casimir mais je te rappelle que très
souvent julie et moi nous avons eu à
subir ttk trice s était pas drôle tu
sais moi moi je n'ai jamais été aussi
désagréable que lui aussi casini enfin
bon c'est pas bien grave casimir
pourquoi n'irait tue pas voir tes amis
quelle famille je sais pas moi qui tu as
beaucoup d'amis casimir va voir tes amis
qui berne avant qu'il ne s'endorme
l'hiver approche et bientôt pas pu les
voir tu as raison mais au moins ce sont
des amis sincères je vais leur rendre
une visite attendue pour casino je te
laisse y aller seul je retourne jouer au
ballon avec les enfants
allez on continue notre françois vient
de me donner une excellente idée je vais
aller voir rihanna et je vais lui faire
croire qu'il est en nominal kiberlain
comme ça il dormira paul iv et moi je
serai tranquille
il ya des moments où j'ai des idées
tellement extraordinaire que je m'étonne
moi même
à tout à l'heure casimir bonne visite à
des amis
au thomas somare la bosse j'ai une
devinette opposera une devinette jarry
j'arrive j'écouterai il y à un mètre de
boudin gagner j'aime pas le boudin mais
je veux bien essayer quand même si je le
gagne je l'offrirai à monsieur martin
bon il adore ça alors écoute monde oui
qu'est ce qui n'a qu'un oeil
lorsqu'il est dans un grenier et 2
lorsqu'il est temps après
aucune idée c'est bien trop difficile
moi je pensais que tu allais me posais
une question dans le genre qu'est ce qui
est blanc quand il est en l'air et et
jaune quand il tombe par terre tüv
aurait répondu quoi attends attends
laisse moi réfléchir c'est léonard qui
m'a appris ça
c'est l'omelette je crois non non c'est
pas c'est pas l'omelette nigaud donc
assez geof l'offre l'offre il est
payante quand on le lance en l'air et
jaune lorsqu'il tombe par terre ne
s'écrase mais revenons à ma question
qu'est ce qui n'a connu au grenier et
deux dans un truc
tout un
pourquoi tout
parce que lorsqu'elle est dans son
grenier elle ne dort que d'un oeil et
lorsqu'elle est dans le vrai elle ouvre
grand les deux hommes ont sonné sonné
pour soi il s'agit bien d'un animal mais
ce n'est pas tout à
ses vaches comme question c'est presque
ça quoi c'est ce à quoi s'est presque
aux vaches allez encore un petit effort
attends attends tu
as tout à toi là quand on parle de la
tortue elle sort de sa carapace
je posais à votre ami thomas une petite
devinette se saurait tout y répondre si
vous croyez que je temps de m'amuser
n'avait rien de plus utile à fort bon
alors illico écoute toujours enfin c'est
intéressant diskin à conoil dans un
grenier les deux ans après
bon bravo bravo
comment ça il s'agit bien du beauf
mais j'ai pas dis bof qu'est-ce que si
j'ai dis bof c'est ça voilà
l'explication d'un de lunettes lol de
beauf est une petite fenêtre qui se
trouvent dans les mansardes et dans les
greniers et le boss vers le box et le
ruminances france connait viager
contrainte alors la fenêtre oeil de
boeuf nakano et le ruminant on a deux
voilà tu as gagné à mettre de boudin
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse
d'en mettre deux [ __ ] je vous laisse
je m'étais juré
[Musique]
tu peux rire petite saute j'arriverai
bien d'attraper vient me chercher
l'oiseau j'ai deux problèmes que je ne
bougerai pas
tu veux qu'on n'aime pas que je me
dérange pour une si petite bête
d'abord j'ai pas la place pour décoller
à vous plutôt que tu as peur de voler
peur de voler mois
ah bon j'ai peur de voler c'est ça mais
j'ai peur de voler
d'abord j'ai horreur des bouches-du
vivante je préfère les vers de terre
ils ont bien meilleure
[Musique]
léonard léonard encore lui qu'est ce que
tu veux eh bien tu sais que l'hiver
approche mais à nantes alors il faudrait
te préparer un coin remet à quoi à
hiberner pire les bébés de quoi me
parles tu as we hiberner dormir tout
l'hiver et pour quoi faire mais enfin
pourquoi faire parce que tous mes amis
dern le clae loire les est courant et
des grenouilles les abeilles et les
renards aussi qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire enfin je n'ai jamais
parlé de ma vie ce n'est pas possible
qu'il n'a jamais hiberner mais enfin
tous les renards hibernent as tu risques
de tomber gravement malade a toutes tous
les autres renards ibères mais bien sûr
mais comment sais-tu ambages hors jeu
j'en ai lu dans son livre et puis
joaillerie sont malades ils aussi tous
les renards ibères qui ne savaient pas
non je suis une seule renard de l'île
aux enfants alors je ne savais pas
hewitt ou les renards s'endorment au
même moment pour se réveiller qu'au
printemps moi je ne dors que la nuit va
justement c'est pour ça que tu risques
d'être mal là tu as beau coup droit car
tu as peut-être raison casimir
maintenant que tu m'en parle
je me sens fatigué et bien ça ne
m'étonne pas je ne sens pas bien du tout
parce que tu ne te sens pas là la tête
un peu lourde à louis ont une raison
d'être également les paupières gourde ah
oui les pompiers retrouvent et les
oreilles lourde à
tous qu'on corps est très lourd
oui oui tu es fatigué tu as sommeil à
vue va dormir léonard tu vas dormir
dormir dormir à l'énarque
dormira léonard
dormir
tu dors
ils ont ramassé
je vais récupérer mon livre pour le
pouce en mousse main pour ne pas le
réveiller
et je vais m'installer
tranquillement
quel plaisir
comme c'est agréable
et voilà je terminais mon livre bonjour
vous êtes là
ne fait pas de bruit
léonard d'or oui il va même dormir tout
l'hiver oui pour être tranquille je lui
ai fait croire que tous les renards
hibernait
je vais vraiment être tranquille pendant
tout l'hiver c'est formidable non je
vais téléphoner cette bonne blague à
monsieur du snob il va apprécier
il est pas là
c'est dommage on va tant pis je
rappellerai plus tard bon qu'est ce que
je pourrais faire maintenant ah j'ai une
idée je réfère montpezat la
has est vrai ni plein
léonard qui ne saurait pas où se trouve
mon passé voilà j'avais oublié il dort 1
c'est quand même dommage lors il aurait
pu me renseigner bon en fait en bien
je vais je vais appeler julie voilà je
vais appliquer julie
à l'eau julie oui c'est moi casimir oui
à sa vaste non pour rien comme ça oui ah
bon ah bon au bar excuse moi excusez moi
je voulais pas perdre en g au bon
d'accord voir
[Musique]
c'est toujours pareil avec julie et
françois toujours la même chose ils sont
toujours en train de travailler au moins
avec léonard peut-être se disputent il a
mauvais caractère mais au moins il est
là quand j'ai besoin de lui
bon qu'est ce que je vais faire
maintenant
je vais peut-être essayer de le
réveiller en en faisant un petit bruit
on va voir
voilà un peu plus fort
il dort toujours rien affaire décidément
léonard est un art tudor
wildor
que cette grande maison est triste
mais c'est quand même dramatique il va
dormir comme ça tout l'hiver mais qu'est
ce que je vais devenir
vraiment alors que la vie est dure quand
on est seul